salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche c'est
le jour des explications et je vais vous
expliquer comment devenir invisible
évidemment je vais pas vous expliquer ça
pour une simple raison c'est pas que je
sais pas faire c'est que c'est un secret
beaucoup trop lourd à porter peut-être
je l'expliquerai à la 366e vidéo on est
dimanche matin jeudi un petit peu
n'importe quoi mais surtout vous êtes en
train de vous réveiller dans votre lit
tranquillement en train de regarder la
vidéo et je vous vois je vous vois car
j'ai piraté la caméra de votre téléphone
parce que je sais que vous êtes sur
votre téléphone portable je sais
beaucoup trop de choses aujourd'hui je
vais vous apprendre à deviner à quel
prénom pense une personne
évidemment il y aura pas de
démonstration parce que 200 personnes je
ne peux pas faire la démonstration mais
vous m'avez déjà vue faire des choses
similaires dont pas mal de vidéos je
vous met une petite fiche avec une vidéo
un peu correspondante comment faire ça
alors qu'on soit bien clair je vous
apprends une méthode très soft la plus
soft possible c'est on va dire l'espèce
deux premières étapes le premier palier
libre à vous après le complexifier dans
la mise en scène ce qui m'intéresse que
vous retenir c'est l'idée et comment on
va interpréter un signe chez quelqu'un
je vais prendre une mise en scène pour
l'exemple et je vais vous donner deux
trois idées différentes pour aller déjà
un peu plus loin en imaginant vous êtes
dans une soirée il ya une vingtaine de
personnes vous vous proposer de faire
l'expérience sur une des personnes elle
doit se placer devant vous et fermez les
yeux vous lui demandez vraiment de
fermer les yeux de jouer le jeu c'est
très important sinon ça ne fonctionnera
pas et vous lui demander de se détendre
au spa de l'hypnose mais une petite
suggestion serait quand même pas mal
donc vous pouvez baisser la voix d'un
demi-ton parlé un petit peu plus
lentement tout en essayant de le
rassurer en lui demandant de se détendre
et d'expirer trois fois très longuement
sa juste comme but de détendre la
personne est de créer un petit lien une
petite connexion avec vous pour vraiment
qu'elle rentre dans le jeu et qu'elles
fassent tout ce que vous lui demandez
dans son esprit à partir de ce moment là
vous lui demander de penser au prénom
d'une des personnes présentes dans la
soirée donc en termes de teck ça
pourrait donner à partir du commandant
ce prénom d'une des personnes qui
présentent de la soirée qui pensent
qu'ils pensent vraiment tu vois ce
prénom dans ta tête et tu les entends tu
le répètes dans ta tête et tu le vois
s'inscrire en toutes lettres devant toi
tu visualise bien les lettres une par
une
c'est la première phase deuxième phase
vous allez l'emmener dans un monde
imaginaire vous allez expliquer à la
personne qu'elle est en train de marcher
dans un chemin boueux à la de la boue
jusqu'aux genoux en fait c'est très très
dur d'avancer donc voulu expliquer ça et
vous lui demander de se visualiser en
train de marcher vraiment en train
d'avancer est en train de regarder ses
jambes lutter contre le ski donne
et à peu près à partir maintenant j'ai
besoin que tu te concentres et que tu
t'imagines en train de marcher mais tu
es en train de marcher dans un chemin
très beau tas de la boue jusqu'aux
chevilles même un petit peu plus au
dessus du tibia juste en dessous du
genou et c'est une boue épaisse une boue
un peu denses et tu vas avoir du mal à
avancer dedans je veux vraiment que tu
imagines dans ta tête que tu es en train
d'avancer dans cette boue en luttant
c'est très compliqué mais tu avances
quand même et tu regardes mentalement
tes jambes pour voir si tu te prends
rien et si tu arrives à avancer tout le
temps mentalement quoi qui se passer
quoi que je dise tu avances mentalement
en regardant tes jambes ça c'était la
deuxième phase on va passer à la
troisième phase où vous allez lui donner
une information très précise qui va vous
permettre d'avoir la bonne indication
vous allez lui expliquer que vous allez
dire toutes les lettres de l'alphabet
lentement et au moment où vous allez
dire la première lettre du prénom de la
personne à qui ils ou elles pensent
alors un grand escalier un escalier jean
sortira de la boue montera et en haut de
l'escalier y aura la personne à qui
penser et mentalement il va regarder
cette personne pour aller le rejoindre
ce qui donnerait dans les grandes lignes
alors que tu es en train d'avancer
d'avancé dans la bouche a appelé toutes
les lettres de l'alphabet une par une et
lentement au moment où je prononcerai la
première lettre du prénom de la personne
que tu as choisis tu visualisera
spontanément instantanément et
volontairement un escalier géant qui
sortira de la boue il fait quelques
mètres de haut est en haut de cet
escalier lie à la personne à qui tu
penses quand cet escalier sortira tu
regarderas cette personne là dans les
yeux en haut de l'escalier retient bien
quand je prononce la lettre de la
personne à qui tu es en train de penser
l'escalier sort se lève avec la personne
à qui tu penses en eau et tu le regardes
dans les yeux c'est parti maintenant a b
c et vous votre daf pendant cette
période là c'est de focaliser uniquement
sur ses paupières
quand on a les yeux fermés quand on a
les paupières closes les mouvements
oculaires sont quand même décelable ne
vous inquiétez pas je me rapproche de la
caméra vous avez dû voir nettement mes
yeux bougent et derrière la paupière ce
qui se passe dans le conditionnement que
vous avez mis en place la personne
regarde vers le bas ce qu'on fait
mentalement on le fait aussi
physiquement donc les yeux sont vraiment
vers le bas au moment où la personne va
s'imaginer l'escalier sortir de la boue
avec la personne tout angle d'escalier
vous lui avait demandé de regarder dans
les yeux directement dans les yeux de la
personne mentalement donc instantanément
mentalement à la personne ne s'imaginait
lever la tête lever les yeux le regard
les yeux de l'autre personne mentalement
mais aussi physiquement ce qui va donner
quelque chose comme ça à peu près
j'espère qu'on voit bien parce que du
coup j'ai du coup les yeux fermés j'ai
du mal à cadrer mais ça fait à peu près
ça elle est en train de marcher comme ça
elle regarde elle regarde et là il ya un
escalier et le regarde en haut
dès que vous avez vu les yeux se levait
vous avez la première lettre en général
dans une soirée où il ya une certaine de
personnes la première lettre suffit à
savoir à qui le spectateur est en train
de penser s'il vous faut une deuxième
lettre vous pouvez faire redescendre
d'escalier avancé faire la même
méthodologie avec la deuxième lettre
qu'en fait vous faites ce que vous
voulez et moi y ait un truc que j'aime
bien faire j'ai écrit une liste de 26
tard sur un papier
le truc que je dis pas je mélange pour
pas que ça se voit c'est que les noms de
famille de chacune de ces stars
commencent par une autre lettre donc il
ya des groupes de musique et des
chanteurs il ya des acteurs c'est que ce
ne sont que des gens populaires en vrai
j'en ai pas 26 d'ailleurs j'en ai 24 que
je lui demande de choisir une star
dedans et je fais tout la même procédure
comme ça juste en trouvant la première
lettre ban
je peux trouver directement la personne
elle qui elle pense pour la révélation
vous pouvez l'écrire sur un bout de
papier lui faire ouvrir les yeux
ensuite lui faire dire et faire voir le
bout de papier à tout le monde vous
pouvez aussi ça c'est drôle pendant que
la personne les yeux fermés mettre la
personne à qui pense devant de lui
demander les yeux fermés de dira qu'il
pense de claquer des doigts d'ouvrir les
yeux la personne est en face à match ce
que je voulais vraiment vous expliquer
aujourd'hui c'était un type ce pour
avoir la première l'est tous les
premières lettres et pouvoir déduire la
fin du prénom c'est une première étape
dans l'escalier des explications de
mentalisme escaliers escalier vous avez
vu j'ai bossé le texte quand même
j'espère vraiment que ça vous aura plus
que vous allez vous entraîner à le faire
là je parle de prénom ça aurait pu être
des légumes seraient plus des films
seraient peut être que vous voulez en
fait l'important c'est de retenir la
méthode essayer de construire quelque
chose avoue quelque chose de bluffant
quelque chose qui vous plaît dans votre
présentation à vous dans votre univers
avoué commencé à exploiter cette
première méthode
merci d'avoir regardé cette explication
du dimanche c'est un plaisir de
commencer cette journée avec vous si
cette explication vous a plu vous pouvez
m'encourage et en blessant petit pouce
en l'air dimanche qui fait tellement
plaisir et en cette magnifique journée
où je crois qu'il va pleuvoir partout en
france vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne et partager la vidéo ça mettra
des petit rayon de soleil dans les
écrans des gens parce que le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
depuis le 1er janvier donc à demain à
17h ciao
star